democracy it's a tricky concept now yes
we all agree that people must have a say
on governmental decisions but on the
other hands we're kind of scared to see
what happens when these citizens are
manipulated by a populist politician
this is why direct democracy and
referendums are quite so controversial
I mean in theory it seems like a great
idea to ask the voters directly about
the very laws that affect them but what
happens when we actually put something
like this into practice
well occasionally you do get a rather
nasty surprise but not always indeed
there is one country that made a direct
democracy a cornerstone of their
political system no to the earth despite
what you might think we are not talking
about Switzerland here this time we're
talking about Liechtenstein
alright alright I I know I know I mean
why should you care about such a small
country well look Liechtenstein it has a
population of less than 38,000
inhabitants but despite their size their
political system is one of a kind
despite being a constitutional monarchy
most of the political decisions in this
Principality are done through
referendums this includes economic
policies social spending and even
citizenship yes that is right if you
want to become a Liechtenstein er your
neighbors get to choose whether to
accept or reject you through a popular
vote even the right to
self-determination can be guaranteed by
referendum this means that any of the
eleven municipalities inside of
Liechtenstein can hold a popular vote to
decide whether they want to stay in the
country or become an independent nation
all sounds pretty crazy right well it
certainly seems to have served
Liechtenstein incredibly well along with
Qatar Liechtenstein is the wealthiest
country on the planet
at least when it comes to GDP per capita
at purchasing power parity this country
is also known for its political
stability its rule of law and its
business friendly policies and well at
this point in the video you might be
beginning to wonder well how is all of
this possible how can you manage to
guarantee such a stable political system
when people can vote in any crazy law
they want simply with a referendum well
this is what we were wondering here at
visual politic - and to figure out the
answer to this question we decided that
the best thing was to go to the country
and ask so we did just that
the town of Regal is a village with no
more than 2,000 inhabitants that
technically could become an independent
sovereign country if it wanted to
so we wanted to find out exactly how
about what happened so we spoke with the
mayor of the town Maria thank you for
joining us today I appreciate you taking
the time to meet with us and just answer
a few a few questions if we could start
off if I could ask what is the legal way
that the town of Rogalla could separate
from the country of Liechtenstein and
how could how could regale hold a
self-determination referendum the system
denk per hour is very moogly thus to be
Felker on any initiative a griffon word
on Danaher
there is Melissa's fiance parry Rankin a
brief desist unrealistic I was - it
somehow chickens I punked varoom the
oddest Daruma stank part well we are
foreign UN's so white Tatsuki hurich
zuly inch time Winston Eastern kleiner
start on the stanky escaped kine and
groomed symmetric and type Punk'd on
those
offseason baboon doubt such tagging and
as far as far as I can see here we've
been in Liechtenstein for a couple of
days the Prince is very well-respected
here isn't it yeah their first is
directly any respects persone own 10k
via sin doc we can't
tortoise first in-house does recently
Rao in Liechtenstein
Andreea tank and the first at how heavy
sigh onin astonished at over helped me
Twizy Onan on the cistern unshown oft
soo cuute a common some bashful behavior
by trait the hot air - requisites thus
the optimum for - rights to the filtrate
thus far say right cystic relish White's
Walter done it by trading them area own
in Topeka trading on the cloud that cc+
house correct
the gap is not nearby HP
Prince hans-adam ii is the wealthiest
monarch in all of europe with a net
worth of more than four billion American
dollars but make no mistake his wealth
doesn't come from his political role but
instead from his business career he is
the owner of the lgt banking group one
of the biggest asset management firms in
Europe he inherited the principality in
1989 and you can say that he is the
father of the direct democracy system
here in Liechtenstein in his book the
state in the third millennium he
outlined a way to implement this system
in a larger country and well this is
what we wanted to talk to him about your
serene highness thank you once again for
being here I really appreciate you
taking time to talk to us and inviting
us to your hyoeun what what do you mean
it's a really broad question but what do
you mean by the state as a service
provider I think the state should really
concentrate on those jobs which the
state can do better than private
industry or better than the local
communities and for me it was also
important when I proposed those changes
of the of the Constitution to also
introduce the right of
self-determination at every village in
leaking stan has the right to leave
standard principality if they think that
they get a better offer from another
country or if they can make more money
or lower taxation or god knows what if
they become independent and that was for
me also important you know also for my
successors and for the politicians to
see really do deliver very good service
on low cost and therefore low cost with
low taxation do you think that lower
cost is is driven by competition yeah
between because the my understanding is
the local governments of Liechtenstein
as you know they have a lot of
self-determination they're also
competing with each other yeah is that
could you tell me a little how that
works
yeah the different we have eleven
villages basically they compete on on on
taxation they compete on the way how
they offer the infrastructure for
instance they give building sites to
some industry knows what day so there is
a certain competition that the services
or whatever so so they compete on these
issues basically so if I was elected
onion and I was living here and I was
looking at eleven different villages I
feel you know again relating into my
experience you know I basically have
like one country where I grew up so I'm
always gonna relate things to the UK but
I think about it if I if I I grew up in
a village called head corn and if like I
guess in the next village over town or
Canterbury or whatever I get pretty much
the same deal is it's not gonna be any
different you know whether I'm working
for someone or starting a business or
applying to the government for a permit
to do something it's always gonna be the
same that here in Liechtenstein if I I
can look at what the different villages
are offering and make a decision yeah
some villages said all we have now
enough manufacturing industry or also
enough foreigners it was also quite an
issue and because if you attract being a
service the service instead
manufacturing industry with it you
attract those the workforce also from
outside because we cannot provide all of
the workforce here not specialists and
so on so basically so there was then a
resistance know we have to stop and
others took up the chances and we're
able then to attract manufacturing or
service industries and they forget more
income for the village and then offer I
don't know
lower taxation or build a new road or a
new school
renovator church or God knows whatever
ideas their head this works
fantastically here but in a country as
large as the United States the UK Spain
do you think this is you know that right
to self sovereignty and that right that
works so well here in a small country do
you think they can work in in the
constitution of of a much larger country
yes yes I think yes I have seen it in
Switzerland they have it they have this
direct democracy they have this
decentralization sometimes the pen
hunter can't on down to the small
villages I've seen it to a certain
degree also in the United States of
course they're from state to state it's
a little bit different but that
influenced me very much and thought
that's basically a good system and to
give the people some say because usually
especially in a very centralized states
as a politician or as monarch being nor
a monarch or president or prime minister
it takes so long until you realize that
there is a problem yeah
and with that problems pop up and
suddenly you see oh I didn't realize
that they suddenly have an initiative
being locally being on statewide level
and then you can solve those problems
puncher earlier okay and Liechtenstein
for reference about 40,000 people so you
go out there you can gather these things
it's interesting because I feel this
should be something Thea like if I can
get a thousand of my friends together
and then put something forward and then
Parliament have to discuss it and if
it's quite a smart idea a constitutional
change at 1500 could happen which you
know prima facie you think this is gonna
be less stable right you know the
immediate thought that comes into the
mind because anyone can change this
right away but this doesn't happen here
and it doesn't seem to happen in other
places that have a similar thing
why do you think that is because many of
those things are discussed on the local
basis and you have people who are in
favor of it or against it and so those
things are much more discussed within
the population within the voting within
the voters and I think that has turned
out to be an advantage added to the
stability if I look at Switzerland for
instance nevertheless I think that we
have even a best system in the Swiss
with the possibility of a veto power by
the reigning prince just to clarify the
Swiss system they also have a similar
system of direct democracy but obviously
no prince to veto it
now before continuing with this
interview we wanted to get in touch with
some politicians from Parliament's the
friar Lister party is the most critical
voice inside of Lichtenstein's the
little sister lately
Vince only has once actually used his
veto power in 1961 it was a hunting law
I have no idea where it was a little
baby then but it was about the hunting
lawyers and he didn't like that and he
didn't sign the law and that was it he
doesn't even have to say why he doesn't
sign it just doesn't sign and since then
it has never been necessary not of
course a threat to have to make use of
the meat powers of course has an effect
on the workings of the Parliament so we
have to get or we have to reach a
consensus in the end I thought that it
would be worthwhile to keep the veto
power of the reigning prince except for
an initiative way the people want
abolish the monarchy because I saw that
sometimes you had in Switzerland votes
which were perhaps not in the long-term
interest of the country of the people
the reigning prince we think in
generations we had 15 or 20 years ago we
had discussions about this dualism
system and people wanted more power but
at the end there was a there was a
referendum and 65% of the people said no
let's keep it like it is he could argue
and I would argue that democracy should
overrule the monarch the monarchic
system but it's the other way around at
the moment and that has been decided by
the baby
referendums they often are you know with
brexit it was like you just had the
people who wanted to leave calling the
people who wanted to stay calling the
people who wanted to leave done and it
was kind of this ongoing theme in
relation to that how do you think you
know in a country that has so many
referendums that people can make
informed decisions they had two things
which we have to take you have to take
into account before you introduce it one
is that you have to start on the local
basis but people can read really get
trained in those kind of direct
democracy referendums initiatives and so
on where they can see what's the effect
of a stupid decision on the village the
city whatever so that I think is is is
one aspect the other aspect is that you
have to inform the people quite a lot we
have in the law and also Switzerland
that you there's a duty to inform give
the order information to have enough
time for the people to before vote
discussions and so on so that that's
very info and and you have to hand out
all the information and neutral basis I
wanted to ask about that because it
seems often the information at least
I've seen is handed out by whichever
newspaper you tend to subscribe to how
does that how is that neutral
information disseminated to the
population government or the village
administration if it's just on their
local vote has to hand out the
information a neutral information where
both sides can put this information
there then they can also put their own
view into there so that's handed out to
all the voters
so they can look it up they organize
meetings and so on so before such a vote
it's really betting the people of
well-informed yeah those I don't know
whenever I tend to read stuff written by
government it's I don't know I think of
myself as reasonably intelligence and I
read some of this stuff and I'm like huh
like it's government's could be verbose
and they're not perhaps the best at
writing things in an easy-to-understand
way is this information presented in a
way that you know it doesn't require a
degree to understand it's kind of like
here's how it is for the everyman it's
your in your own interest if you're
really in a stupid way or in a way which
nobody understands is going to be
rejected right yeah of course you have
to check that they D write it in a
correct way and you can appeal to that
2/3 to the courts so if there is wrong
information in there
as I ventured Lichtenstein by by various
measures the highest GDP per capita in
the world so a very very wealthy country
and you know we've been walking around
and it's reflected in you know
beautifully clean streets just a lovely
looking place but it wasn't always like
this was it it was it was quite
different so I think I read kind of
agrarian was the term can you tell me a
little bit about about the history of
Lichtenstein kind of before you know
it's it's relatively recent economic
success well one of my previous around
1700 bought the governing rights of
those they were two counties in the Holy
Roman Empire it was basically a vote
buying exercise because you voted to
Emperor and so for him to get more
influence in the Holy Roman Empire as a
prince of the Holy Roman Empire he
bought those voting rights because it
was very pruned and the families who
were raining and were always went
bankrupt he could have caused support by
his huge estates there was no problem
those two counties and put them together
made the Principality out of it
so if he he buys the lands because the
possession of the land is what gives him
the voting rights not really the
possession of the land but it was the
reigning powers over the land okay sir
the length will still be partly in
private ownership that was separated it
was some kind of private would bought
some counties there were accounts here
who went bankrupt and to pay for the for
the people what they owed money then
there was a court in the Holy Roman
Empire where they just sort of auctioned
it off the governing rights and my
predecessor 17 century was
very rich and he paid the highest price
for that so I wasn't in wait there was
still private landownership it was he
was buying the the governing rights over
what is today election shine yes yeah
nobody was really interested in the land
the first one to moved here to lift an
horse my father in 1938 and the first of
all to whiz it what one of his answers a
pretty safe support he came there I
think when a railway was built
throughout Austria sometimes in the
middle of the nineteenth century
so hundreds of estate now I could go
visit this is like that I purchased
what's that yeah they of course they
always denominated someone to represent
them and they paid for the people they
introduced reforms they paid for the
education of people one of the first
countries to introduce more less free
educational education on a statewide
basis so yeah well try to develop it
yeah so it existed at that point you're
you said your father was the first one
to move here why what changed is was it
at some around the time of the war or
what caused yeah what basically the
family lived on the huge estates what is
now the Czech Republic and all their
palaces in Vienna
anyway whole summer states in Austria
still but then when Hitler took over
Austria
one didn't know what would happen with
leash mastitis and when the German
troops marched into Austria my father
who was not yet the reigning prince his
his great uncle was married to a Jewish
Baroness the family was very much
anti-nazi for probably not it was best
friends the rainy Prince fled to
Czechoslovakia over the border and my
father drove to liechtenstein with his
car met German troops marching towards
Vienna and tried to stabilize it here
yeah and luckily he succeeded we were
not the next
there was a small there was a small
attempt of a coup d'etat he unleashed in
the way a Nazi Party yes when my father
I think in 1938 just before the outbreak
of world war ii the small naughty nazi
party by the support of some Nazi people
outside as in the governor of Tyrol and
fall back or southern Germany supported
they tried to make a march on reduce
like the march on Rome
but the duche it was a bad copy in both
both yeah but then the people heard
about it it's not so much of course you
couldn't keep it secret so people came
together the farmers at that time you
know with all the instruments Taconic at
the forks and all the walks which was
its own they surrounded them we don't
have a country
your father was was here and he
established what exists today
essentially that's right when the
reigning princes came to visit before
they build
Villa up here but they came with a
settlement it was only built in the
second half of the nineteenth century
when the first came to visit but then
people wanted to have the castle which
was before a museum adapted so that it
will be the residence of the reigning
prince and this is where we are and
that's why
now most people think that Liechtenstein
just became rich because of their low
taxes and their secret banking laws but
this couldn't be further from reality
now of course the financial sector does
play a big role here but in fact the
industrial sector is the biggest
economic power in Liechtenstein have you
heard of the company Hill T or IVA carve
evidence well if you haven't heard of
that last one the next time you go into
the dentist have a look at the brands of
tools they use most likely they were
made in Liechtenstein well it's a hit
the company that is still in the
Buckingham Palace I I'm guessing that
they updated it from this version
already but yes the buckingham palace is
heated by a heating system out of
Liechtenstein so we were we were kind of
talking and we spoke with other people
as well about the employment situation
in Liechtenstein cos about 40,000 people
in the country but a lot of people come
from around to to work here kind of as a
commute right lelouch line actually has
more working places than we have
inhabitants so we have roughly 38
thousand inhabitants and 39,000 chops
that means we're heavily dependent on
commuters that come into the country
each day I think it's about 20,000
people that come here each day and what
are these people typically doing most of
them work in the industries and like for
the biggest companies like Hilty like
the Evoque law or the to synchro questa
relates to the economy of Liechtenstein
and you know I appreciate the history
things I didn't didn't even know after
doing the research for all of this
what what kind of drove the change from
the agrarian Licht engineer from I
suppose how it was before your father
arrived and then set things up here to
Lichtenstein as it is today because
while it was at 60 or 70 years it's in a
way it's it that seems like a lot of
time but in a way it's and not a lot of
time for such a dramatic transformation
I seen there were several factors which
were important one factor was or in the
19th century when one of my predecessors
introduced
general schooling
we have one of the first states to
introduce it I think worldwide I sing in
Europe because on thought because it was
a poor country relying on the subsidies
of the reigning princes
so at least we should educate the people
so they can't find a job outside of
Liechtenstein if they don't find one
inside yeah one kept the taxation as low
as possible so to attract business one
was then able to make double avila the
customs treaty with the austin hungarian
empire that opened up the big market
before you know for the local market
hopeless is very small it was too small
so with the access to this large market
or one could attract the swiss textile
industry yeah because if we are across
the border but next to it but there was
a free trade with that otherwise they
would have had to pay taxes its I'm just
thinking if the similarities with today
kind of how in the past it was we're a
very small country we want to trade with
austria-hungary and now it's like
European Union in a way a similar thing
you have just more country and we we saw
healthy the the tool manufacturers the
dental stuff of course low taxation
which is something we'll discuss in a
bit
people I think often have these these
notions where they're like they think of
something and they're like why is a
place rich and Switzerland rather the
Liechtenstein as an example low taxes
right but the reality is it's it's often
more than that whether it's education an
education and then also access to the
markets yeah if you don't have access to
markets we couldn't even feed our own
people they were dependent on subsidies
by the reigning prince and of course it
became better with Valley it was fine
with also knowing they're an empire and
then after it collapsed luckily we got
the same treaty with Switzerland and I
was able to push through thanks to the
éric rohmer cracy the European economic
market because
there was a lot of resistance government
in Parliament and would not have got
through that but with direct democracy I
was able to put it into a popular vote
you know about this drawer we have
several advantages here in Liechtenstein
one is this that the taxes are not too
high the other is we are actually in the
middle of Europe well if you've seen the
distance since you're everywhere within
no time right we're staying in
Switzerland while we're here in
Liechtenstein just over the border
there's you were mentioning the people
commuting from Austria and Germany so
right in the middle we are also located
in two different economic areas at the
same time so we have very easy access to
the Swiss Economic Area and but we're
also part of the European Economic Area
right right next door to the EU right
next door to you yes and we have both we
have contracts that makes it very easy
so if you like for example if you have
an insurance company and it is based in
Liechtenstein you just need one office
to work in Switzerland and in the EU
well if you don't have it in
Liechtenstein then you need two separate
offices
do you think that the removal of the
secret banking that was there was here
before do you think that do you think
that affected Lichtenstein's economy
much it reduce for short terms a tax
income but against my more pessimistic
look at it I was very much in favor of
opening it up because it exposes so much
criticism it
none of those banks or the financial
industry they recovered after two three
years perhaps also because I always said
we are not going to be able to uphold
this banking secrecy which was
introduced some time before world war
two but the Swiss and so on so that
that's changing yo you have really to to
if you want to survive in the long term
as a bank or in the financial industry
you have to offer good service for
people who are willing to pay also their
taxes in their home country I think
that's another thing that I picked up on
was with these smaller states you can
really focus on you know instead of you
like you say the reality is this is the
way the world is going people need to be
open with their finances this is how
it's going to how it's going to be and
then you could switch to a focus on
let's do really good banking let's be
really excellent banks let's not be you
know generic and giant bank who won't
pick up the phone on Saturday morning to
let's be really good at this which is do
you think that's another one of the
reasons why you know Liechtenstein as an
economy has done so well because you can
focus on doing things really well rather
than I think so yes I think it was the
education system it was low taxation it
was a realization that you would only be
able to survive in a small
as a small country in an economic with
no home market
you had to compete on the world markets
to survive and nobody's going to protect
you
the government cannot afford to support
one of our larger manufacturing
companies we would be just then we would
have to raise taxes and there would be a
media initiative but the people in the
popular world why why should we pay more
taxes to support mr. Osterberg mr. hefty
mr. mayor mr. whatever moolah this is
well like your system because like I
feel this sometimes happens in in other
countries maybe my earth at least we
don't really get a say it's like yeah we
um we just gave them loose of money
because they were in trouble
lepen Trump you Kip why now do you do
you have an opinion on why why do you
think this is happening now
we see changes in the whole system of a
direct democracy people get more
detached everything has become
complicated you have globalization
there's not so much possibility to
decide only for your state all that
makes people to a certain degree unhappy
and therefore populism easy solutions
that people never really had looked very
much in why this law that law like
Switzerland over here there was also in
Switzerland populist movements to a
certain degree on on immigration but
that quieten down when it was solved
more or less and here there were also
some but not very much and and that I
think is something that has somehow
worried me for quite some time that
those states who are my opinion to
surgery over centralized are not
fulfilling any more duties which are
spected from the people and that creates
populism and and and easy solutions and
things like this
the middle of easy solutions the appeal
of easy solution here is the solution
their often their catastrophes yes
narrowly avoided sometimes do you think
increasing globalization you know maybe
is going to lead to more of this do you
think this is is something we're gonna
see continue or do you think this is
kind of something we're gonna see fade
away as people perhaps realize that you
know once we've elected a populous
they're not or they cracked up to be
it's I don't think it's going to fade
away because globalization is going to
increase you really I think you have to
adapt to this new situation and really
you know the old nation-state and
socialist state told the people that we
are going to produce heaven here on
earth and that doesn't turn out like
that and so there's a resentment on that
and people have the feeling that people
up there they don't contact anymore with
us they're detached they are just
looking for their own positions their
own money and that creates these kind of
populism and and that's icing a danger
for democracy and that worries that's
one of the reasons why wrote by book
I just wanna has been a real pleasure
it's a it's a skeevies and have you give
me your thoughts and everything that you
- it's been a pleasure it was an
interesting discussion for me talk glass
thank you very much thank you
now as we often say here a visual
politic not everything is perfect and
despite the success of Lichtenstein's
model there are still many questions is
it legitimate that the head of state is
not chosen by his citizens could this
system really be implemented in bigger
nations well now it's your turn please
do leave your answer in the comment
section below we'd love to hear from you
and perhaps many of you right now you're
hungry for a little bit more well if
that is the case we do have a bonus for
you you can watch the entire interview
with The Prince and it has many many
more questions in it in that video we
talked about history the war on drugs
and of course immigration especially to
rich people moved in before it put their
deals restrictions because of the low
taxation they would buy nice houses nice
building places whereas the local people
couldn't afford it now this video is
only going to be available to you our
patreon supporters and if you do want to
become a supporter and get that bonus
material please do check out our patreon
page we really appreciate it for less
than the price of a cup of coffee per
month you can help us to continue this
project called visual politic and also
make it bigger and more ambitious and as
I mentioned you will also get access to
the whole Prince hans-adam interview as
well as other exclusive content that
we're going to be publishing in the
future so please do check that out
there's a link in the description below
and also if you like this video please
do give it a thumbs up and as always
I'll see you in the next one